sherry Ryan fight hey guys I'm Ryan
right Jerry Jerry Jerry Jerry tonight
we're gonna watch the new trailer for
the new Mortal Kombat game brand new off
the press off the presses there's a
little Irish boy selling newspapers down
street right now every time I get a new
notification that there's a comet that's
been made on any video it's the same
thing watch the new Mortal Kombat
trailer I don't know what a DiDio game
by actions you suddenly got really cool
I know I can't quite pinpoint what you
did it's cuz we're inside because we're
inside you got shades on since you're
ten times cooler now yeah and now like
people can see the studio lights so it's
like it's like it's like that cool like
Hitchcock effect yeah it's like you can
see the behind this yes that's [ __ ]
awesome yeah yeah when I think of Mortal
Kombat I was thinking of a movie I loved
the movie still do it's like one of the
best 90s movies ever hate have you seen
what is the best video game movie only
only in the sense that it does seem to
capture the look and vibe oh yeah they
took a fighting game and they turn it
into like a story - it's ripped off
Enter the Dragon but other than that it
was still pretty [ __ ] cool I mean is
how easy the fight scenes are cool
awesome it's certainly silly but they
did at least it seemed like whoever made
the movie at least cared about the game
someone the Mortal Kombat annihilation
oh that was awful still kind of like it
just because Mortal Kombat yeah cuz I
did grow up playing the Mortal Kombat
games I'll be honest I be kept up to
date with like the latest Mortal Kombat
games like I don't know what we're about
to watch well it was a big deal when
they brought it back a couple of years
ago for PlayStation 3 wasn't it Mortal
Kombat is like that's a legendary video
game man for its time that was a very
violent game prolific fighting game
that's when like that was like a
controversial game for like hell violin
and [ __ ] was rip people's spines is
this filth with Internet the coolest
fighting moves - [ __ ] I'm excited to
watch this trailer swatches
may contain content inappropriate for
children bad
yes those that score of you he's gonna
like Bane is awesome it's like a real
fight and like in the video game butter
like a movie clip version sub-zero you
gotta make a comeback mode oh damn
yeah that looks awesome dude this would
be the third game trailer I've seen this
year this is the first norm like I'm
gonna buy this because I think I can
play this game like for sure I don't
know what the actual game will be like
that looks like yeah more like a
cutscene than than a taste for what the
actual gameplay would be like but that's
I mean certainly about it see that's
where I kind of disagree but I don't
know for sure if I'm disagreeing who's
alive
well that that certainly doesn't look
like people playing no but with the kind
of graphics and gameplay they can do
today it looks like it's a hybrid of
like a movie clip cinematic clip but how
the gameplay can actually be yeah I mean
I'm sure it's all the moves you can do
and stuff like that but that's awesome
about it cuz you know you watch a lot of
these like cinematic clips for games and
then it's like a lot of this [ __ ] the
cool characters do that you can't
actually do when you're playing with
them oh no yeah and I feel like you can
do that with these characters and I
imagine it seems like they might go so
far as to borrow a page from something
like burnout worried they actually take
time to zoom in on a move and show you
bones breaking in blood yes Cordy I'm
just saying like with a clip like this
I'm like that's a super awesome
you know cutscene or whatever it is you
know it's like it's possible to make a
really totally cool video clip that
doesn't translate into a video game so I
just don't know what the video game
itself would be like but the clip is
[ __ ] rad
the clips rad but all I'm saying is
Jerry is that the moves they're doing I
think you can do in the game yeah I
think this is an awesome trailer it
makes me want to check out the game but
I don't know the game well I just it
just doesn't give me a taste for what
the game will be like I just said look
at all that it's like negative works are
going off in here yeah that could have
been better if you're new to the channel
hit that button we're moving on so we're
gonna do some shout outs here Eric Lupo
said you are just like the best person
to react to trailers and you also are
very inspiration that is like a weird
think this is read in one sentence you
react the trailers is quite an
inspiration you take time out of your
day
to watch a trailer well maybe that maybe
this maybe Eric Lupo has seen some of
your other videos that's true I have
done other things besides what you've
done more a bit more personal like vlog
e stuff yeah there's some short films up
there too yeah maybe that's true
yeah but you got me to realize that I am
I have a lot of potential yeah thank you
I am an inspiration I am an inspiration
and man people have said they've started
making videos because of you so I guess
they are that I guess your inspiration
oh well thank you
Jerry yeah Eric you son of a [ __ ] your
son of a [ __ ] you know and De Niro cry
to go to Joe Joe Pesci busts in and then
just immediately starts a weeping Julio
where I can have a shout-out I'm such a
big fan of your that's caught that's
apostrophe re Channel I pointed out for
a reason my friend I've been subscribed
to you for a long time and I'm also
going to be graduating high school in
the next two weeks
when did I grab this yeah I don't know
if it's ready bastard graduation or not
it stands to ruin it might be it might
but yeah congratulations congratulations
my friend that's not easy you're gonna
go to college now you're gonna pursue a
career that you probably don't want to
pursue but your parents really talked
you into it
hey maybe take a year off see the world
see the world you know a lot of people
wish they did that and you should do
that
see the world [ __ ] some Italian girls
man go out there have some fun you know
your dick sucked by a guy who knows my
before you fishie fishie gaming he said
or she said hey Ryan did you see my
shout-out request years.she given
earlier shout out requests I didn't give
it to them at the expected time frame
they had so they wanted to ask me did
you see my shadow we did now fishy-fishy
gaming
there you go fishy fishy gaming fishy
fishy gave me hungry hungry mr. dance my
friend
good fishy fishy gave me whenever you
walked through the room fishy fishy gave
me about take off your pants fishy fishy
hey I feel like this is a sick con yeah
we're gonna go whoo when you do yeah
that's your catchphrase because fishy
fishy gaming